what do you mean when you say that your
ideas are different than your feelings
because obviously your ideas are some
what influenced by your feelings and
your perceptions yes how do you
disentangle them
my ideas are stories that i construct
they i have agency over my ideas my i
don't have agency over my feelings
before i'm endowed
when i'm a child my feelings are
the result of the interaction between
the
model that the mind maintains of the
universe and the model that it maintains
of the self according to the needs
of that self right so when uh things
happen in the universe the mind
evaluates them as good or bad which
means they're frustrate needs or they
satisfy needs and as a result the self
represents uh joy or suffering
and
when
the mind is con
it doesn't have the correct intrinsic
model an innate model that you're born
with and how to interact with the
environment then your needs are going to
be constantly frustrated
so for instance i
grew up in a forest
far remote from other villages and when
i got into first grade and met other
kids pretty much for the first time i
had difficulty relating to them they
were not interested in the same things
as i was i was a nerd i was reading a
lot i was interested in
math and physics and
science fiction and
history and stories and so on and other
kids were interested in soccer
and i couldn't get myself to be
interested in soccer and as a result i
was excluded from many of the games and
later the same thing happened with
respect to politics it was eastern
germany you were expected to pretend
that you conform with the prevailing
ideas and if you didn't you were
punished
and even if these ideas were illogical
and at the same time your teachers told
you to be critical and don't take in all
the ideas from your environment without
criticism because you know this is how
fascism happened in germany people took
in bad ideas from the environment
without criticizing them they did not
develop moral agency so i thought
the thing that i'm doing that i question
everything that i want to know why
something is the way it is and you need
to explain it to me before i believe you
um
that would be a virtuous thing and uh so
it was an apparent hypocrisy that my
teachers told me one thing and uh i
behaved according to that and that
punished me if i did this
right it was difficult for me as a child
to make sense of that and as a result i
basically decided at some level and it
was not something that was deeply
reflected but it was inevitable to
distressed my emotions i had to because
they were wrong they were not pointing
me in the right direction i had to form
theories on how things work
and i think in a healthy mind this
development is temporary you are a being
that is directed by its intuitions and
these intuitions are something that is
uh trained it's not something that is
random or superstitious
it's your intuition that tells you
whether this is going to be a good
relationship or not but there should
marry that person or not but this person
should be your friend or not but you
should take this job or another because
if you try to make proofs about this
you're not going to get anywhere it's
way too complicated you're thinking your
ideas are way too brittle
and science is in some sense the part of
our mind that is meant to deal with our
darkest and murkiest emotions with those
where we don't have solid intuitions
right so it's science has marginal value
only for the individual largely you need
good intuitions it has also only
marginal value for society not every
ought to be a scientist that society
wouldn't work like that because science
is too brittle the ideas that scientists
come up with don't tell you what kind of
relationship you should enter
and if you overvalue science
then your society is going to go astray
you need to have solid common sense you
need to have good intuitions good
understanding of how things work and
only in those areas where these
intuitions break down where you need to
make proofs this is where science really
helps and shines